des informations du prochain rapport du
giec qui détaille l'impact du
réchauffement climatique en fuite et
elle conclut que la hausse des
températures de 1 5° seulement pourrait
entraîner des conséquences graves
pendant des siècles et parfois
irréversibles inondations famines le
verdict est terrifiant apocalyptique les
énergies fossiles sont responsables de
70 % des émissions de co2 les pays du
monde entier doivent en conséquence
mener des politiques drastiques pour
limiter leur exploitation mais ce n'est
pas possible parce qu'ils ont traité le
traité sur la charte de l'énergie dit et
c'est eux donnent des pouvoirs
inconsidérés aux compagnies énergétiques
ce traité a été signé en 1994 par 53
pays dont les pays européens
le kazakhstan le tadjikistan le japon
son objectif était de sécuriser
l'approvisionnement en énergie fossile
des pays d'europe à partir des anciennes
nations du bloc soviétique
le tc a prévu une protection des
investissements des compagnies
énergétiques
mais aujourd'hui les objectifs de la
transition écologique vont diminuer ses
profits or en vertu de ce traité un
investisseur étranger peut poursuivre
les états qui menacent et intérêts
devant un tribunal privé bien plus
favorable aux compagnies que les
tribunaux nationaux
ce traité méconnu et 10 écocide obsolète
par ses détracteurs il est une entrave à
la transition écologique pour deux
raisons primo les compagnies exploitant
des énergies fossiles exige des
milliards de compensation le t.cae a
jusqu'ici permis de traiter 135 plainte
avec des additions de millions ou
centaines de millions réglée par les
états selon l'analyste des politiques
énergétiques yamina seb
le coût de ces plaintes pourraient
s'élever à plus de 1000 milliards en
2050 dont 42 pour cent seraient payés
par les contribuables
secundo ces compagnies peuvent influer
sur l'élaboration des législations
nationales qui deviennent anti
environnementales en france en 2010 est
nicolas hulot préparer une loi pour
interdire l'exploitation et
l'exploration d'hydrocarbures d'ici 2040
l'une des principales entreprises
exploitant des concessions
d'hydrocarbures en france le canadien
vers millions avait alors écrit au
conseil d'état la lettre de ses avocats
évoqué ce projet de loi ces attentes
légitimes faisant planer la menace d'un
procès le conseil d'état alors
conseillé de continuer à protéger les
opérateurs miniers nicolas hulot a dû
plier et reculer alors que faire
modifier le traité un sixième cycle de
discussions se tient du 6 au 9 juillet
pour le faire évoluer la commission
européenne venait de proposer un projet
de révision qui a été d'emblée rejeté
par les autres signataires la ministre
de la transition écologique barbara
pompili s'est emporté devant l'assemblée
nationale le 22 juin dernier le
processus de modernisation du traité qui
est engagée de en 2020 ne semble pour
être très clair pas être en bonne voie
tous les états ne semble malheureusement
pas partager les ambitions européennes
en matière climatique c'est pourquoi
nous envisageons de proposer un retrait
coordonné de l'union européenne et de
ses états membres est il imaginable de
quitter l'accord comme l'italien en 2016
une clause crépusculaire qui porte bien
son nom prévoit que les compagnies
pourront toujours attaquer l'état
sortant durant 20 ans c'est pourquoi à
l'instar de barbara pompidou plus de 300
députés européens et nationaux ont
enjoint les états de l'union à faire une
sortie coordonnée de l'accord avec un
pacte de non agression
plus de 400 ong ont plaidé pour cette
sortie des signataires d'ici la réunion
de la coop 26 en novembre 2000 21
glasgow mais pour le moment une poignée
de compagnies énergétiques continuent à
avoir gain de cause et à faire monter la
température